say to you at your colleagues who want
to bring back the death penalty in this
country well that's not my view that's
not the the government's view but we are
united in the conservative party and
wanting to be absolutely Relentless in
bearing down on crime and making sure
people are safe and feel safe that's why
we recently tightened up sentencing laws
for the most violent criminals so they
spend longer in prison it's why we're on
our way to having 20 000 more police
officers on our street and we're giving
those police officers more powers to
tackle crime whether it's stop and
search or just this week in Parliament
we're giving police officers the power
to tackle violent and extremist
protesters that's because we want to
make sure people are safe they feel safe
and that's what we're delivering